turn your hips hands up elbows in lower
your center pull the punches back pull
them back to the guard you're dropping
that hand on that rear cross pull the
punch back
pull the punch back
you're dropping that hand Tristan on the
rear cross
lower your center you too high
get underneath this Center when you hit
underneath you're too high you're too
far out lower you're too far out is your
foot six inches away from his foot no
it's too far out
you're not driving through do it again
get your hips close to the target pull
those punches back turn your hips lower
yourself don't overextend step close
turn your hips go again she dug oh
you're not turning your hips fully